There's no one on this planet
that can stop me, send them all
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is
my Black Adam post credit scene video and
breakdown of the ending hopefully you've had
a chance to see the movie the ending sets up a
bunch of stuff everyone has been asking about
for the last couple of years so it's really
good news if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen the movie
yet but if you've been praying for Warner
Brothers to bring back Henry Cavill as Superman
congratulations the ritual sacrifices you've
been performing in your basement for the past two
years have worked they totally did all the things
the answer on that is that it's actually the rock
who's responsible for Henry Cavill being able to
come back even in the first place as Superman
like previously the regime that was in place
before this didn't want Henry Cavill to be the
one to come back but at the end of the movie
Black Adam successfully defeats and kills sabbac
who has essentially created a demon version of
the Shazam and Black Adam characters like sabbac
works like the Shazam and Black Adam characters
work they're granted the power of a group of
gods so the Shazam acronym stands for specific
different gods but it's different for the Black
Adam character and different gods for the Shazam
character they're accurate to that in the movie
in for the sabbac character it's the same thing
but it's a group of demons that Grant him his
power the human that becomes empowered as the
next sebok is basically like The Last Descendant
of the previous King Of kondak Who Lived during
black Adam's original time period 5000 years
ago the big MacGuffin of the movie is The
eternium Ore it's the dceu version of vibranium
basically if you were thinking of He-Man and
the Masters of the Universe the minute you
heard this in the theater you're not alone
I have eternium is a thing from DC Comics it
sounds like it's from He-Man and the Masters of
the Universe but eternium inside the DC Universe
are just shards of the rock of Eternity that have
fallen to Earth so that's basically what they're
mining in conduct over in the Marvel Universe
vibranium isn't magical but you get the idea
super rare super powerful or that only exists in
one specific place and at that time in history
the king had forced his slaves including Black
Adam and his family to mine eternium ore which
they use to create the crown of sabbac which
is Loosely based on the comics like sabbac is a
villain from the Shazam comics the king wants to
use the crown to take the power of sabok thinking
that he'll become a God but all the demons that
are granting him the power or would theoretically
Grant him the power just want to use him as a
conduit to get between the underworld Dimension
where they're stuck in the normal dceu Dimension
even if it wasn't clear at the movie the demons
basically used the Sabbat character to open that
portal subak himself wasn't doing that he was sort
of like a glorified finger puppet for the demons
but in present day The Last Descendant of that
previous king of conduct completes what the
previous King could not before Black Adam killed
him in Revenge gains the powers of the Demons
becomes a demon version of the Black Adam Shazam
characters opens the portal and then obviously
Black Adam has to kill him after he's done with
that he vows to become conduct's protector like
he is in the comics like his son used to be in the
dceu there's a statue of Black Adam in conduct but
they revealed that the statue was actually of
his son when he was wielding the power his son
granted him the power to help save his life but
then his son was killed shortly after because
he didn't have the powers to protect him so Black
Adam basically says he's going to carry up where
his son left off like fulfill his son's dream of a
better world trying to make khandaq a better place
and during this ending scene they keep putting
the Amon character the son of his future love
interest Adrianna Tomaz in red capes obviously
foreshadowing for the Superman post-credits scene
the Justice League easter eggs during the movie
like a mod is meant to be a superhero Justice
League Fanboy and has a bunch of their merch
all over for his room he runs around with a bag
of Justice League Comics all the Justice League
easter eggs all the comics he has all the artwork
he has around his room all the action figures
is all based on real life merch like actual DC
Comics actual DC art like Jim Lee Batman art
all the Superman art is based on real Superman
posters you could go out and buy some sort of like
a mishmash of Justice League merch inside the dceu
that's Canon now to the dceu but as if the designs
have been based on other real world comic book art
that you and I could go out and buy also for those
of you wanting cyborg to come back in the future
of the DCEU movies the comics he runs around with
inside his backpack are cyborg Comics so it's
like they're saying that he's still around in the
dceu but he has Aquaman stuff Wonder Woman stuff
he even has flash stuff even though it definitely
sounds like they're going to recast that character
after The Flash movie but I'd say of all the
Justice League easter eggs most of them are
focused on the Superman easter eggs they're like
a lot of references a lot of Superman jokes that
they have with the merch during the movie like
a man's red cake that the justice Society gives
him but also when Black Adam is inside his room
looking around at all the Justice League merch not
really knowing what's going on because he wakes
up after 5 000 years not knowing who the Justice
League characters are like who are these people
like what is all this crap and he keeps destroying
pictures or action figures of Superman like he
even blasts one of the Superman posters through
the chest with his magical lightning like I see
what you're doing there very clearly foreshadowing
the Black Adam vs Superman movie that The Rock has
been hyping up he did say that they're actually
working on that like they're actually going to
pay off the post-credits scene in an actual movie
and in this ending scene Amon wearing the red
cape standing with his mother Adrianna Tomaz and
Black Adam says he's going to change his name to
something more modern which is him just taking the
actual Black Adam name because for the majority of
the movie he just calls himself teth Adam no one
ever actually calls him Black Adam also because
Amon is a proxy for black adam's son Adrianna
Tomaz is a proxy for his dead wife throughout the
movie and especially at the end they set up the
idea that he eventually will share his power with
them granting them the powers of of Shazam the
same way that Billy Batson did with the shazamily
in the first shazam movie and if you're not a long
time Black Adam comic book reader this is right
out of the comics like he does Grant a portion of
his power to Adrianna Tomaz and in the comics it's
her younger brother but in the movies it's her son
that'll probably be plot that they cover in Black
Adam too in The Rock when he was promoting the
movie said oh you know here's a really interesting
character who doesn't have powers yet like I said
she's going to get powers in the future and I
think this is going to be the Twist and he was
talking about Adrianna Tomaz so because they're
basing a lot of this on the comic book plot
Loosely I think what they're implying with Amon
and Adrianna getting Powers is that something
will go off the rails and that's why Superman gets
involved like a mod will try to use his powers and
cause some huge accident and that's why Superman
gets involved and because the sequel will probably
be a lot of that Superman vs Black Adam energy
it'll probably start with him giving powers to
Amon and then they Captain America Civil War the
plot with Amon being kind of like the Bucky in
Black Adam being sort of like the Captain America
figure in that equation like super man comes to
find out what's going on with Amon going crazy
with his powers trying to stop him and Black Adam
gets really pissed off because Superman lays hands
on his surrogate son but then we get the actual
post-credits scene so after Adrianna and Amon go
home the Justice Society take off there's a short
time Jump and Knight has fallen Amanda Waller
sends a drone to Black Adam at the ruins of the
palace and because earlier in the movie he had
broken out of her underwater Suicide Squad task
force x prison with a bunch of other metahumans
she says it's fine that you didn't want to stay
in my prison but now khandaq is your prison you
try to step outside the borders I will send more
powerful people to stop you I'll call in all the
favors that I need to that's a reference to the
larger Justice League characters that's why they
had so many Justice League specific easter eggs
earlier in the movie Just to set up the idea that
this was a connected universe and that she would
be able to call the Justice League like this is
why I sent the Justice Society first because the
more powerful people that I can call are the big
favors I need to call in if things get even worse
and because he's got this whole thing in the movie
and The Rock has been using this as a big catch
phrase is when he's been promoting the film the
past couple years about being the most powerful
character on this planet like he's very careful
to say most powerful character on this particular
planet Amanda Waller's big clap back at him is
that she can call more powerful beings than him
who are from other planets he kind of smirks at
her and destroys the Drone and then Henry Cavill
Superman descends through the smoke while the John
Williams classic Superman theme song plays he says
it's been a long time since someone has made the
Earth this nervous and that they should talk he's
wearing a very tuned up looking version of the
classic colors if you look really closely too the
other thing you may have noticed is that he also
has the classic Superman curl in his hair which is
different from the previous movie so far I believe
this is also the first time that they've actually
used the classic John Williams Superman theme in
the new dceu movies because all the times you've
seen Superman before like even when he came back
in the Justice League Snyder cut he was still the
Han Zimmer Superman music not the John Williams
Superman music then it goes back to the credits
and according to the rock that specifically
meant to set up Superman vs Black Adam in the
sequel like I said the reason they go at it may
be early prediction it'll have something to do
with Amon getting powers and it's something that
Amon does on accident and that's why Superman gets
involved like why he would actually care about
what's happening in khandaq Amon causes some
International disaster on accident and that's why
Superman gets involved because the whole idea is
they want both of their actions to be justified
like why are they fighting each other why is
Superman going after Black Adam because Black Adam
is supposed to be protecting this surrogate son
and Superman is trying to protect the rest of the
world in separately all the Justice League easter
eggs earlier in the Superman Cameo scene at the
end together are meant to foreshadow future Black
Adam versus the justice league in the movies like
Black Adam with the entire team not just Superman
but that's like later on I think the first thing
we're gonna see is Black Adam versus Superman but
Zachary Levi has also said that the next time they
work up to a Justice League movie Shazam would be
on the team so like they want to work in the Black
Adam and Shazam characters to the Justice League
franchise and this is sort of the way they do that
through the Black Adam vs Superman in Black Adam
too but you get the idea Black Adam versus the
Justice League like he called them out on notice
in earlier promos last year that's the reason he
was putting them on blast earlier talking about
the hierarchy of power in the dceu changing but
what will happen is my full breakdown in easter
eggs for the entire movie will post next on
Saturday in my house the Dragon episode 10
finale video will post Sunday after they release
it so be sure to enable alerts for my channel so
you don't miss any of that click here for that
full Black Adam breakdown easter eggs video
I'll update the link as soon as I post it and
click here for my house of the Dragon episode
10 video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!